في الصحراء المحيطة بدبي
عندما تمطر 25 يومًا فقط في المتوسط
يًا ، ي
عب الحصول على مصادر المياه ، لك
إحدى الشركات تقول إنها تنتج مل
ون ونصف لتر من مياه الشرب هن
كل عام عن طريق جعل الماء بع
دًا عن ضوء الشمس والترحيب بالهواء  إلى
مصدر المياه ،
يهدف مصدر المزرعة إلى توفير مياه شرب نظيفة
لأكثر من ملياري
شخص
يعيشون في البلدان التي تعاني من ندرة المياه ، تعمل
عشرات الشركات في جميع أنحاء
العالم على تقنيات تستخدم
الهواء لصنع مياه الشرب ،
لكن المصدر يقول إن عمليتها
مستدامة تمامًا
الفكرة الكبيرة وراء المصدر هي توفير
مياه الشرب المثالية لكل شخص في كل
مكان
للقيام بهذا المصدر ، طورت تقنية
يسمونها
الألواح المائية ، حيث يستخدم الجهاز
الطاقة الشمسية لتشغيل مروحة تسحب
الهواء ، ثم يتم توجيه هذا الهواء إلى شكل
يشبه الإسفنج  المواد
التي يتم فيها امتصاص جزيئات الماء
لتقطير وتجميع
هذه الألواح المائية تنتج بشكل فعال
جودة عالية  مياه الشرب يومًا بعد يوم
دون الحاجة إلى أي بنية تحتية ، أي
طاقة
أو أي نوع من الشبكات التي تعمل حاليًا
في 48 دولة ،
اختار المصدر دبي لتكون أكبر
مزرعة
مياه لها ، وأنشأت الشركة نفسها هنا في عام
لأنها تقول إن المنطقة حريصة على
الاستثمار في هذه الحلول
ما جذبنا إلى دبي هو أولاً وقبل
كل شيء حقيقة أنها مركز لمنطقة
الشرق
الأوسط وأفريقيا ، كما أنها مركز
للابتكارات الجديدة
للقطاعات الرئيسية مثل الزراعة والمياه ،
ويقول خبراء إن أحد أكبر
التحديات التي تواجه هذه التكنولوجيا
هو  تعتقد صعوبة توزيع
المشروبات على نطاق أوسع أن العقبة الأكبر
تتمثل في جعل الناس معتادون على الفكرة كما هو الحال
مع معظم
التقنيات التخريبية ، حيث يتردد الناس في البداية
في تغييرهم ويترددون في
تجربة شيء
جديد وينطبق الشيء نفسه على قطاع المياه الذي
اعتاد عليه الناس هنا  الحل الأساسي
لتوليد المياه وما
نقترحه هو نوع من قائمة متنوعة
فعالة
في مصدر دبي  تعمل شركة e في هذا المخيم الصحراوي
المشهور بالمسافرين ، لكن
طموحات الشركة تمتد إلى ما هو أبعد من
مناطق الجذب السياحي ، فهي
موجودة بالفعل في خمس
قارات ويقولون إنهم يعملون مع
المدارس والفنادق والمجتمعات
المحلية ، وبما أن نقطة انطلاق المصدر هي
الشمس والهواء فقط
قد تكون السماء هي الحد الأقصى آنا ستيوارت
cnn
[موسيقى]